when it comes to beings with fearsome
reputations there are few scps that are
as widely dreaded as the hard to destroy
reptile
scp-682 no sane mortal would ever choose
to face such a creature and it's
overwhelming ferocity and strength have
even given the reincarnating warrior
scp-076-2 able pause on more than one
occasion but then again this saying
aren't exactly in high demand at the SCP
Foundation or at equivalent
organizations formed for the purpose of
battling anomalous and Supernatural
entities organizations such as the
public safety devil hunters from the
popular Manga and Anime chainsaw man
count numerous peculiar individuals
among their ranks and sometimes the best
of the best are marked by a distinctive
tendency for out of the box thinking
that's putting it politely at least but
this isn't the story of some aberrant
loser Freakazoid no definitely not the
hair island of this tale is none other
than the mightiest and most charismatic
future Nobel Prize winner ever to Grace
the rest of us shameful worms with her
presence the Invincible and dearly
beloved blood fiend power who just so
happens to be the Undisputed best
character in chainsaw man and of all
fiction as well it appeared to be an
unusually Boring Day At Public Safety
and for this kobeni was grateful the
young woman had come to expect the
absolute worst from her job as a devil
Hunter as her assignments usually
entailed facing down hellish entities
born from the very fears of the human
race while one would think that someone
who worked so diligently in the field
would have grown numb to it all kobeni
still very much retained her anxieties
both on and off the job at least all she
had to do today was file paperwork from
one of the public safety's like-minded
Partners in Supernatural management the
SCP Foundation it was a safe and
harmless task aside from the risk of
Supercuts and the associated potential
for the paper cut devil to show up even
so kobeni would do her best to make this
rare moment of Peace last as long as
possible a voice cried from down the
hallway oh no not her cobeni thought why
is she even at work today she's a
fighter for division four and she's not
good at anything else loud exaggerated
footsteps rang out through the hallway
as the blood fiends stomped through the
offices of Public Safety cabani wanted
to shrink until she vanished from sight
or let herself sink into the floor her
desire to not have to see Power today
was so great that she contemplated
opening a window and climbing down this
side of the building to the ground floor
please don't come this way kobeni was
still carrying a heavy stack of freshly
filed paperwork and she didn't want her
tireless efforts at organization to go
to waste she looked frantically at the
cabinets in the storage room she was in
hoping to find enough space for her to
crawl into and make herself scarce but
it was to too late power slammed open
the door of the storage room and
announced her presence the shock was so
great that kobeni screamed and flung the
stack of SCP Foundation papers all over
the ground she clutched her fast Beating
Heart unable to attend to the mess
immediately kobeni hadn't had to
experience a fright that sudden since
the time that she was sent to hunt the
jump scare devil the poor girl could
never have a surprise party thrown in
her honor again Drew to her name power
immediately reprimanded cobeni for
dropping the papers stating that her
workmanship was sloppy and that power
herself could easily carry 10 times the
amount of paper kobeni tried to not let
the chatting of her co-worker affect her
mood she bent down and scooped up the
papers but much to her Chagrin power
decided to help with this task as well
the bloodstream began grabbing the
papers and stacking them as assertively
as possible on the nearest surfaces
resulting in many crumpled edges and
uneven piles kobeni attempted albeit
hesitantly to correct power's paper
collect method only to be met with more
scorn gobending nearly cried this was
just too much for her to handle
especially on what was supposed to be a
calm day that was when power picked up
one of the files and began to read it
was a record of the infamous cross test
between
scp-682 and
scp-076-2 since Public Safety had
previously assisted the foundation in
re-containing
scp-076-2 there had been an agreement to
send copies of all relevant documents
involving Abel over to Japan in case of
another incident as power struggled
through the scientific language and
specifics she began to Envision her own
version of the events that played out on
the page she imagined herself as able
facing off in pitched combat against
scp-682 and giving the terrible lizard a
run for its money in the process in the
mere seconds it took for power to finish
reading the document she had not only
concocted an entire epic battle in mind
but was not fully events that her
fantasy was indistinguishable from one
of her own lived experiences in her head
power had definitely fought against
scp-682 and she'd do it again in a
heartbeat just to teach that overgrown
reptile another lesson power asked
kobeni if she had ever told her about
the time that the blood fiend had
totally defeated
scp-682 kobene is still clutching to her
increasingly frail understanding of
reality responded with confusion what
was she talking about nobody in public
safety had fought against an SCP other
than
076-2 there was no possible way that
power was telling the truth but the
scariest part was power herself didn't
even know that she was lying the blood
fiend began to relate the Sora details
of her pulse-pounding fight with scp-682
tukubeni in great detail cabani for her
part was too emotionally drained at this
point to try and stop her it all started
at the bowling alley Where power was
hanging out with her much less
intelligent friends Aki and denji the
bloodfiend had just finished winning her
fifth perfectly scored game in a row
when some shady characters a few lanes
over decided to cause some trouble the
leader of this little gang was none
other than
scp-682 the way you ball is disgusting
the troublemaking lizard said this
wicked remark would not be stood for not
in the proud bowling establishment that
power had founded with her own money and
achieved several years of successful
business running herself the bowling
alley was a pillar of the community and
she was the owner there would be no
further disrespect on her watch power
put up her dukes and got ready to bring
the pain down on scp-682 Aki and denji
were too terrified to help her out as
usual but did their best to cheer their
leader on from the sidelines
scp-682 also dismissed its minions and
called forward like the big ugly lizard
that it was it obviously didn't know
better which is is why it wasn't backing
down in the face of the greatest devil
hunter that the world had ever known
either way this would be a Brawl for the
ages rather than cause damage to her
beloved place of business power
suggested that she and her opponent took
this fight outside despite its uncouth
demeanor the reptile had a healthy
appreciation for the fine sport of
bowling and most especially this
particularly excellent run five-star
bowling alley it agreed to step outside
in the interest of not bringing bowling
into this intensely personal Grudge
Match but then again wasn't the fight
about bowling no matter power in scp-682
walked outside the bowling alley into a
vast trackless Wasteland the perfect
place for both of them to go all out
without hurting any civilians using her
ability to control and reshape her own
blood power constructed an enormous
Crimson Mallet that she was able to
wield gracefully in both her hands
despite its incredible size scpc 682
readied itself it had faced many
different kinds of humanoid weapon
wielders before including Abel but it
was too clever of an adversary to let
its guard down especially because in
this case the blood fiend it was
fighting was a remarkable businesswoman
and an Olympic gold medalist in
everything the reptile certainly let its
card down power held the hammer above
her head and jumped High into the air if
she wanted to she could have circled the
globe in a single leap but out of
respect for the fact that scp-682 was a
paying customer at her establishment she
decided to hold back for the first
attack at least nonetheless she brought
the hammer down on the hard to destroy
reptile with Supreme Force
scp-682 smashed into the ground with
such a force that a crater opened up
beneath its body the reptile itself
didn't seem especially damaged but the
effects on the surrounding environment
were certainly dramatic and fitting for
an Ultimate Showdown
scp-682 shook off the blow and pounced
on power such ferocity that even she
couldn't remain on her feet she tumbled
back into the dust and debris of the
Wasteland for several miles before
catching herself and standing back up
remarkably there wasn't even a scratch
on her she pointed and laughed at
scp-682 mocking it for its weakness and
stupidity the reptile grinned wickedly
and responded with a mocking laugh of
its own the creature had intentionally
taken a hit from power in order to
better understand her fighting moves who
wouldn't want to steal those masterful
techniques after all they're just too
good to resist making a cheap copy of
and from what power could remember from
her speed read of the file that appeared
to be
scp-682's whole thing soon a barting of
blood red armor appeared around
scp-682's body in the short time that it
had been fighting Power it had clearly
learned how to manipulate its own blood
and was now even stronger for it ha ha
ha
now I'm as strong as you I can't lose
scp-682 barked at Power she swung her
Mallet in a show of force the two
combatants now both wielding the near
Limitless powers of the blood fiend
charged at each other across the
battlefield this was not just a mere
sparring match anymore it was a fight
for the fate of the entire world
snapping back to reality Powers
retelling of the story had devolved into
a series of random exclamations and
sound effects cabani was now finding the
events incredibly hard to follow but
thankfully she had been able to use
powers highly distractible mannerisms to
finish restacking the files from the
foundation not a minute too soon either
as both she and Powers boss makima
stepped into the storage room apparently
makima was in the process of doing a
headcount of all employees who had come
into work today as any normal and
benevolent Superior would she had been
looking for kobenian power for some time
now and was surprised to find them here
of all places cabani explained that she
had been putting away the last of the
SCP Foundation files and would gladly
accept whatever new post she was given
but Power wasn't done with her current
scp-682 Fascination and turned to makama
hoping to be encouraged to continue the
story makama simply smiled and implied
that if power was so inclined to settle
her score with a hard to destroy reptile
Public Safety could get in contact with
the foundation and have her on a flight
to site 19 by that evening power
suddenly realized that she had come down
with a terrible case of whatever
crippling disease that would be a
sufficient excuse for her to not do that
makima nodded and encouraged her
subordinates to return to work want an
anomaly of your own check out
scpswag.com for high quality SCP merch
now go check out Rick and Morty more
powerful than SCP Foundation mad
scientist battle and scp-096 vs siren
head for more crazy crossovers